all right now to the Wildfire situation
it is still a tense wait for residents
off Tumbler Ridge British Columbia the
fire is just kilometers away from the
community but as residents head into a
fourth day out of their homes there is
some good news from officials today
Romina Daya is on the front lines and
she joins us now with more Romina
pharah yesterday was a heavy day for
Tumbler Ridge evacuees who thought their
town was going to be gone for sure but
it's still standing
an army of firefighters and volunteers
from across the province are in Tumblr
Ridge Crews have been spraying down
homes and infrastructure to protect the
buildings in case the fire starts moving
aggressively again more Sprinklers and
more resources are on Route the crews
hoping their presence will give evacuees
some peace of mind we're doing the best
we can trying to get as prepared as we
can for for what might come this way
with the fire so close we're we're
hoping that we'll be able to do
everything we can to to save their
community and even if it's just
reassurance over you know talking to you
that homes are okay and we're doing our
best to protect them can't guarantee
outcomes but we're here doing our best
to
to do what we can to save it
2 400 residents were ordered to leave
their homes Thursday when the fire
exploded The Blaze currently about 4
millimeters away from town while it
looks like a normal day today it's
dangerously deceiving the sprinkle of
rain not enough to make a dent the risk
is still very high you know that doesn't
change the fuel content or the moisture
in the ground so it feels good but we're
not there yet
here crews are taking advantage of the
weather right now laying fire breaks but
this isn't going to last it's a fluid
situation the wild card is the wind
pharah
Romina Daya near Tumbler Ridge British
Columbia thanks Romina